this fighting around Batman I mean it is
brutal it is messy and it is just going
on for a very long time we've been
reporting on it for over six months now
the Ferocious fighting continues but
actually from the chaos of this war
there are some themes starting to emerge
now if you look at the Russian push-up
in criminal and down in valladar largely
despite huge casualties it looks like
the Russian forces are culminated they
haven't made that much ground around
back moot slightly different story
you'll remember the Vagner group was
leading around there then the leader of
the Varna group you have any pre goes in
got a bit too big for his boots replaced
by the Russian army but actually they
made no progress at all it looks like a
Wagner group are back in control they
are making limited progress but it's
very difficult going from the Ukrainian
perspective they're also gaining having
a lot of casualties but it is worth
remembering on the defense you generally
only lose a third of the casualties you
do on offense so it's normally three to
one and the ukrainians are claiming
they're inflicting seven to one
casualties on the Russian forces now
that sounds a bit extreme except for the
fact Russians are throwing these
inexperienced novices into the fight
really difficult but I mean the sort of
losses you're talking about are
extraordinary what does it mean for
Russian forces more broadly
well they had um 300 000 if you remember
that they mobilized and it looks like
they now need more but for president
future it's gonna be really difficult
domestically to actually Mount another
mobilization even if he did that creates
quantity and not quality unless they
change the taxes on the battlefield
you'll get exactly the same results but
it's not just people it's also equipment
you've heard about the Wagner group
running out of ammo but also if it's
true that two-thirds of the Russian
tanks have been taken out of Supply it
now emerges they're bringing 800 of
their old t-62 main battle tanks shown
here out of long-term storage these are
60 years old expecting to put them into
battle now they are bulletproof but they
don't have any of the technology of a
modern battle tank they don't have the
weapon aiming facility at the reactive
armor so they'll make the Russian forces
very vulnerable what's a real tragedy
here is the T14 main battle tank which
is the Armada tank that's the
state-of-the-art tank that was due to be
into the service with Russia two years
ago for a whole bundle of reasons not
least of which corruption that has not
entered the service yet right what about
the impact on Ukrainian Force list it's
a huge price that Ukraine have been
paying as a result of this Russian
invasion they risk getting drawn into a
war of attrition this is bakmut's uh an
absolute wreck Ukraine bear in mind is a
smaller Nation they've got a smaller
pool resources both in terms of Army and
in terms of equipment and they just
don't want to get drawn into a war of
attrition but at the end of this
completely it's completely devastated
but once the the point is eventually the
Russians will culminate they're already
culminating two areas when they do will
Ukraine have sufficient capacity and
reserves in order to mount their own
counter-attack because that
counter-attack will be vital if Ukraine
is to Prevail in this summer if it is to
actually liberate some of its lands I
mean these are extraordinary images all
right uh Sean thank you very much indeed
thank you